many visitors came here for the weekend
thousands of workers
aren't back to work at our local resorts
leaving a gap when it comes to staffing
8 news now reporter victoria saha joins
us live on the strip this afternoon and
victoria there is an issue many
properties
are dealing with right now
there's been various posts on social
media to people expecting pre-pandemic
treatment to claims that there aren't
enough staffing
especially when they see a lot of people
i reached out to the culinary union they
can confirm not everyone is back to work
50 percent of the 60 thousand union
members are still
unemployed the union is fighting for
their workers to return to the jobs they
had pre-pandemic
but there's an issue here it's not the
matter of filling these positions up
but according to the culinary union
places like station casinos that fired
thousands of people during the pandemic
are now wanting the workers to reapply
and compete for the jobs they had before
they say it's not right station casino
says well over a thousand of our former
team members have returned to work at
various station casino properties
and they're all being paid at the same
or a higher rate that they're receiving
the same or even better benefits upon
their rehiring
and that doesn't include the large
increase to wages we made just last
month
the nevada resorts association tells us
in part as occupancy levels are
increased and visitation builds and
becomes more predictable
we will see more employees return which
is what our members
have been looking forward to since the
march closure now i did reach out to
several strip resorts
so far mgm and wynn resorts couldn't
confirm or deny that they are
seeing a staffing issue because of the
influx of visitors here
but the convention center says that back
in february we had over a million
visitors
in las vegas reporting on the strip
victoria saha 8 news now